the creative team behind rise of the
beasts are introducing three new robot
tribes maximals Predacons and terracons
to the existing battle on Earth between
the Autobots and Decepticons the
introduction of these new cybertronians
will change the course of the autobot
Decepticon war that viewers have seen so
far the Predacons and terracons fall on
the side of the Decepticons while the
maximoles are a new tribe of Heroes
Optimus primal is the leader of the
maximals and transforms into a
gorilla-like beast the terracons are the
main villains of the film and they are
led by Scourge a merciless Predator who
takes pleasure in stealing insignias
from the Fallen Autobots he defeats the
maximals Ally themselves with the
autobots and since this is a prequel we
know the heroes don't succeed in wiping
out the Decepticons but fan favorite
characters like Optimus Prime and
Bumblebee will live to fight another day